here's a shocker the college coach who
helped kyle murray become a heisman
trophy winner is defending kyler murray
against concerns about his height
lincoln riley the oklahoma coach says
size doesn't matter and you know i don't
think height matters but what matters to
me is that overall frame that overall
ability to take an nfl pounding i see
kyler murray and i think that this is a
guy who if he gets hit enough times he
potentially is going to get injured
that's what my concern would be now
riley seems to think it won't be an
issue because he says that kyle murray
is faster than any quarterback in the
nfl and he'll be the fastest guy in the
nfl and and i don't know how lincoln
riley knows that if he hasn't coached at
the nfl level there's a fundamental
difference between the speed of the
college game and the professional game
kyler murray either is going to be
faster than everyone or he isn't and
he's going to find out the hard way and
his team may find out the hard way if he
isn't fast enough to run away from these
very large and strong and fast nfl
players and i hope kyle murray works out
i hope he's as electrifying as patrick
mahomes i hope he revolutionizes the
game and i hope that we never again
think twice about a guy who may not be
north of six feet but at least for now
these are concerns that people are going
to have and they're not going to go away
until we see what kyler murray can do at
the nfl level
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports